hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the paul
morphy saga and after this um 1858
simultaneous exhibition match
morphe played in birmingham where he
faced eight opponents simultaneously
blindfold
uh now it's again time to revisit uh his
match with howard staunton
and uh what uh what will happen with
this match will morphe even face taunton
uh well stonton uh has accepted the
match and he
morphy said that he will play a match
anywhere in between 100 pounds
all the way up to 1 000 pounds and the
match was agreed upon
to be played for 500 pounds and even
though
uh 500 pounds might not seem all that
much to you
nowadays in 1858 that was a whole lot of
money
uh by using an inflation calculator
online
i have learned that uh 500 pounds in
1858 would be
62 540 uh
pounds today so that's uh that's a lot
of money and
the problem was uh morphy's uh morphy's
parents did not allow morphe to play
uh for money because morphe although he
was very young morphy did turn
uh 21 uh by the time he turned 21 in
july and this was played in august and
he didn't have to listen to his parents
but his parents said that if he
plays for money off or if he embarrasses
the family in any way
that they will send soldiers
over to england to drag him back to new
orleans and
morphy had a plan morphe uh even when he
uh
uh played against lodental he uh okay
they played for 100 pounds but
uh morphe if he lost of course
the plan was for morphe not to lose so
if you don't lose you don't have to
you know give any money and in case
morphe won and uh
won some money from long tile then
morphy would decline the money so either
way
no money goes to or uh you know uh
uh goes from or comes to to to morph his
hands so
that's how he was uh handling that uh
but
what's very interesting is that even
when morphe was still um
in the united states and he was playing
chess there he did play for money we all
remember the
300 match uh morphy played uh against
love until when aluminum visited new
orleans and
there were also some lesser matches of
one hundred dollars and his
family seemed to be okay with that but
now for some reason uh
they did not want morphe to play any
anymore for money
so that could present uh itself to be a
problem but
morphy agreed to the terms uh and the
staunton said as the quote above the
board says that i will play you at the
beginning of november
and like we said that uh simultaneous
exhibition that took place in birmingham
uh
was somewhere in august i think uh so he
did have some time until the beginning
of november
uh to face some other chess players so
morphy visited paris and
there he will face some very very strong
players uh well while traveling there
uh morphy said that he wasn't feeling
all that great
but that he would still very much uh
like to crush everyone uh of course i
mean
why else would he go there and he will
meet uh
for for the first match you will meet
daniel horowitz and he was one of the
strongest players there uh but uh first
uh
when he first arrived morphe did not
introduce himself and of course nobody
no
no one knew what he looked like so he
came to the famous cafe del argenza yeah
and
there he uh spectated some of the games
that were being played and he learned
from
whispers from around uh the tables that
uh daniel horowitz will be arriving on
saturday so more we had some time
uh to check out the other players and
maybe even challenge them as
well and cafe del argenza is uh is the
the most
famous uh bar maybe even they had a
library i don't know but it's the
definitely the most famous bar in the
world uh where chess has been played and
some of the
most famous names in the world have been
known to play chess there
some of the names that i will mention uh
are for example benjamin franklin played
it there and
benjamin franklin played there with
philidor and none other
maximilian robespierre also played there
napoleon played there himself
of the famous french players ke cerzke
rosenthal and la bordene played there
uh howard staunton played a match there
against saint aman in 1843 and in 184
in 1867 wilhelm steinitz also visited
and played in a tournament uh he didn't
won i think he wants a second place but
he didn't play and also karl marx met
with
freddie hengels also in this cafe in
1844 so
some uh 14 years uh before uh
morphy's well matches uh that took place
here
and i even got a photo of coffee dollar
against if you guys are interested i'm
gonna show it to you
uh let me just load it uh because all
right
so this is uh what it looks like today i
i don't have
any ways of uh knowing if this is
actually it but this is what it looks
like today
so if any of you are from paris and you
know you have been to this place maybe
you can
confirm that this is in fact the one
that uh you know
has the over 300 years old tradition
so if this is uh the exact one and here
i have also one
i'm just going to show you uh it's it's
closest to the one
uh to the asia where morphe played this
is from 1854
and i'm going to show you what it looked
back then so this is basically uh
how it looked back then and i don't know
it does
appear to be the same cafe uh but you
know
like i said for those of you who are
maybe from paris maybe you know if they
you know redecorated or maybe they moved
it or maybe it was closed and
then reopened somewhere else but this is
basically the place and it says it was
founded in
1718 uh which you know that's uh
uh i don't know if it's the longest
existing bar
but uh it definitely has tradition and
some of the most famous names not only
in chess but also in
in the entire world played there so that
being said
uh morphe's first opponent here okay he
played some lesser matches here and
the games were not recorded um he played
some blindfold games some uh
games with the odds of a pawn in the
movie and he pretty much crushed
everyone
but here is the first serious opponent
that he faces and that's uh paul giorno
i don't know if i'm pronouncing these
names right i mean uh
i've never never actually learned how to
properly pronounce french names so you
are welcome to you know uh
mention in the comments how to pronounce
it if we ever
uh stumble upon such a name again and
here he faces paul jordan like i said uh
he was a member of the cafe dealer
against a chess club in paris and he was
one of the leading french masters uh
from 1850 to 1860
and it's uh it's a very interesting game
so let's check it out uh first we're
going to show a few games
uh morphe played against journal and
then we're gonna see what else happened
in
in paris during morphy's visit here and
what will be
uh of the match with howard staunton so
morphy has the white pieces and as usual
uh he opens with e4
uh journal plays c5 he goes for the
sicilian defense we have d4
striking immediately in the center and c
captures on d4 so a bit of a different
move order than how how it is played
today knight to f3
and now e5 defending the spawn and it's
interesting it seems like the pawn is
hanging but not really if the knight is
captured then queen to a5 check and you
lose a knight
i remember when i started uh playing
chess i of course was
going through some more fees games uh
morphe games and i i was feeling uh you
know
uh invincible and then i came to this
tournament i think it was a blitz
tournament and my opponent played this
with black and i actually fell into this
trap
and i was like wow i mean uh
i mean again i have no id
the uh what just happened but i
blundered a piece and then i immediately
resigned it was
pretty crazy uh but okay of course
morphe's opponent
uh i did not manage to trap morphe morph
we just continued development bishop to
c4
we have bishop to e7 black also
continues development and
c3 now now challenging the center and
preparing to develop the queen via the
b3 square and then he's going to go
after the f7 pawn
and black says no not a problem today a
modern player would play something like
knight to f6 prepare to castle
but his opponent played the d6 and he
said i don't mind you can grab an f7
it's not a problem
and interestingly this position has
never been reached again uh in
tournament play but
um that's not all that uh all that
impressive because
white is definitely better here so queen
to that's not a queen
queen to b3 going after f7 and not just
d captures in c3 in those days in 1858
you didn't really care if uh you know
you you were denied castling privileges
so bishop captures an f7 with check king
to f8 and now
knight carter's in c3 and black just
continues developing knight to c6
uh preparing knight to a5 to try and get
the queen away from the defense of the
bishop here
so murphy just grabs the knight bishop
captures ng8 rook
captures and now he castles the safety
and now queen to e8 now the queen can
come to f7 you can offer a queen trade
and all is well the problem is black has
uh
does not have enough time for that here
morphe goes knight to g5
and now he's threatening knight captures
on on h7 with
checkmate because the queen is covering
the f7 square uh the knight has to be
captured so this is what your note does
bishop captures on g5 with bishop
captures on g5
and now bishop to e6 attacking morphy's
queen
hoping for morphy to capture on b7 to
allow black for some rapid development
uh but morphy not interested morphy just
goes knight to d5 now
the knight is is a nuisance there you
have to be very careful and
there isn't really a good move here for
black now so what can black play here
nothing really uh the move played by
journal is actually the second strongest
move recommended by the engine but even
that's not enough
uh he played h6 trying to kick away
morphy's bishop
but the position is now completely lost
so feel free to pause the video and
win this beautiful short game for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
f file must open up
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's f4
f4 and black can resign there's no good
move here
uh the thing is if you go after the
bishop h captures on g5
then just uh f captures on g5 this comes
with
check and the king has nowhere to go the
knight covers the e7 square you have to
block this and after you block this with
the bishop otherwise you can block with
the queen but you're just going to lose
the queen
g6 is incoming and there's just no
defense here
rook captures is is happening and if
neither defends here it's not a problem
just g captures knight captures and now
knight to c7
attacking the queen the rook the queen
can't really move because queen captures
an f7 will be checkmate
so even if you move the queen somewhere
you can just capture the rook the other
rule comes into the game you can double
rooks ndf file anything you do here is
winning for white and when i say
anything i mean
most of the moves so here after this h6
move morphe did play f4 like we said and
now comes a move that uh well does not
capture the bishop but rather
it comes with uh f captures on e5 for
morphe because uh queen to d7 was played
so getting the queen a little bit to
safety freeing up the e8 square for the
king
but it doesn't matter f captures on e5
by morphe again
a discovered check from the rook king to
e8 and now comes uh
the the brilliancy that ends the game on
the spot
uh of course you will see it knight to
c7 with check
so now the king is in check and there is
no move all of these squares are covered
so
the knight must be captured the queen
captures on c7 was played
and here morphy just played queen
captures on e6 with check and it was in
this position that paul george resigned
in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh what you could do is you could block
uh
check for example knight to e7 if you
don't want to give up the queen right
away
but the then comes e captures on d6 now
attacking the queen and the knight
and yes you do have a little bit of a
defense with queen c5 check
and being able to win the bishop but
it's not enough and journal
saw to this and then uh he just resigned
but i will show it
after the king moves and you pick up the
bishop yes you're not getting checkmated
because the
the queen covers the e7 square however
rook to f7 and black
has no defense king to d8 if you try and
run away but now
rook captures on e7 threatening
checkmate here and after queen b5
guarding against checkmate just
queen captures and g8 there is no
defense queen blocks and then queen
delivers checkmate
so journal was a very strong player
himself he saw all of this and it was in
this position on move 17
that uh paul should not resign to the
game as
like i said there is nothing more to be
done here so morphy starts uh starts
the uh well his paris tour with a great
victory
uh we'll see what else happens in paris
a lot of great games were played here
and then we are continuing the howard
staunton saga
because you know that's what what this
is all about
uh so yeah uh there's the game i hope
you guys enjoyed it and a little bit of
uh
info uh prior to the game i would like
to thank william shreer ashley barr
somewhat scholarly youtube uh dallas
paulson and jerry fitzgerald for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
if
you're just starting out with the morphe
saga there is always a link in the
description below where you can start
the morphe saga from the beginning to
catch up with with the rest of us
uh see you soon